hello hey honey how are the kids
everything's great
in track track he's an excellent health
we started earlier than we ever have on
this film Ralph the production designer
and I were the first two artists on the
film and the way it would start is he he
would do sketches on newsprint based on
things that he was seeing come right off
of the script out of Brad's head because
we wanted to get in there early and
figure things out my name is Maya abou
Sadie and I am the director of
photography for the camera and staging
department the Pixar is it is based on
that kind of live-action vocabulary we
want the camera the characters to feel
physical we want the moves to feel like
they have weight
my name is Tony Fedele I'm one of the
supervising animators there's three of
us on the show so that's this fine
balance of pushing the action have some
vitality and then balancing that with
the reality of the physics hi I'm Corey
hi Yoko I'm an animator here at Pixar
with every set of hands that touch these
shots you're adding a layer of subtle
character detail my name is Brynn and
McGary
I'm shading art director I feel like
this one has a scale that is much larger
when you look at the cities and things
there's an element of fantastic but also
real my name is Nathan Ferris I am its
that supervisor on Incredibles 2 I
really like the cities so to watch that
go from really rough you know previz to
finished product it's a costume design
for animation is no different than
costume design for a live-action it's a
huge team effort for Nunis costumes to
the screen it'll be incredible it'll be
incredible promise combustion imminent
what does that mean
it means fire Robert
[Music]
[Music]